hi everyone I'm Stacie about a year ago
I started using twisted for a BitTorrent
client that I was writing as a project
at hacker school then last summer I
worked full time as a developer on
twisted and became a committer so I've
spent a lot of time trying to unravel
twisted and I'm here to share what I've
learned in this introduction but before
we get into what twist it is let's take
a whirlwind tour of some of the things
we can do with it
twist it comes with a bunch of
configurable servers which can be run
from the command line using the twisty
utility all of these servers were
written using the twisted library itself
so here's the command to spin up a web
server on port 8080 which serves static
and dynamic content out of the current
working directory we could run a chat
server which authenticates users from
the information in a file or a name
server which uses information from a
host file to translate domain names to
IP addresses or a secure shell server
which authenticates users with the SSH
keys on the server or we could run a
server which shares the files in the
current directory these are all examples
of the kind of powerful applications
that we can build ourselves with twisted
now let's go back to the beginning with
twisted is an event-driven networking
engine in Python but briefly about what
that means then we'll cover twisted
abstraction for event-driven programming
and networking we'll talk about uses
low-level and high-level api's and
finally we'll talk a little bit more
about the capabilities that twisted
offers out-of-the-box twisted is a
library which provides built for
creating Network locations is programs
that communicate with other computers
over a network twisted makes it easy to
write programs to talk to other
computers using standard protocols HTTP
for accessing web resources P for
transferring files SMTP for sending mail
and many more twisted also provides
tools
we can use to implement our own
protocols and it provides worth
limitations of clients and servers for
many standard protocols one of the
notable characteristics of network
communications is that when one computer
sends a request to another the response
isn't available immediately because the
messages have to travel back and forth
across the network because of this
characteristic the event-driven style of
programming organization works really
well for Network applications in an
event-driven system program flow is
determined by external events in twisted
case primarily Network events three
programs use this style also but the
events are things like mouse clicks or
button presses to understand why
event-driven programming works well for
network applications let's look at some
alternate models first let's say we have
three castes that are independent of one
another
perhaps fetching web pages from three
different sites in the single threaded
synchronous model the processor runs one
task at a time from beginning to end
because it's synchronous when a task
needs to do a network operation it has
to wait till the results available
before it can move on the gray areas
here show the time the processor is
waiting which is known as blocking this
model isn't very time efficient it would
be really nice to use the processor to
do other work while a task is blocked
but it's very easy to follow what's
happening in the code in the
multi-threaded synchronous model task is
assigned to its own thread thread and
runs from beginning to end the operating
system is responsible for allocating
processing time among the threads
possibly on multiple processors or
interleaved on the same processor this
is much more time efficient because when
one task blocks other tasks can proceed
however is much more complex than the
single threaded model because control
can switch between threads at any time
it makes it harder to reason about the
program flow and we have to take special
care with shared resources so that
they're not corrupted inadvertently the
event-driven model is single threaded
but asynchronous instead of blocking on
a network operation as a task in a
synchronous program would a task and an
asynchronous program you
other tasks can all the waits for the
network up please an event-driven
program is organized around an event
loop which waits for events to occur and
dispatches them to call functions which
have been registered to handle the
events the inventor of a model displays
the best characteristics of the other
two like the single threaded model one
test runs at a time eliminating a lot of
complexity but like the multi threaded
model it's time efficient now we'll take
a look at the abstractions that twisted
offers to support event-driven
programming twist ins event loop is
called the reactor that's because it
reacts to events it repeatedly waits for
network and timer events to occur and
invokes the callback which has been
registered to handle each event a
callback is simply a method on a Python
object entwisted all code execution
occurs as a result of an either a
network or a timer event the reactor
needs to use functionality provided by
the operating system to perform network
communications and to efficiently detect
events from operating system operating
system the eyes may vary but Twista
provides a unified
hides of the differences by providing a
variety of different reactor
implementations the interface for the
reactor provides a way to start it stop
it and schedule functions to run at a
later time for server we can tell the
reactor to listen for various types of
incoming connections and to an it and
for a client we can tell it to initiate
a connection to a server the listening
connection func
functions set up callbacks to run when
the connections established one thing to
note that once the reactor starts it has
total control of the program and other
codes only run in response to events so
before it started we have to make sure
to tell the reactor to listen for at
least one event otherwise it will run
forever
with no way to register any further
callbacks when an event occurs and a
callback is invoked control passes from
the reactor to application code and the
application code will continue to run it
until it explicitly returns control to
the reactor that should happen when the
task is doing completes or if it needs
to block on a network operation instead
of blocking the application code should
register a callback with the reactor to
be run when the operation completes and
then the application code should return
control to the reactor in reality things
are a little more complicated we might
want several things to happen when the
operation completes and we might want a
separate callback to handle error
conditions Twista provides a very nice
abstraction for managing Koch's called a
deferred the first are one of the more
complicated parts of twisted I'm going
to go over the basics but don't worry if
you don't catch all the details they
won't be necessary to understand the
rest of the talk so we can think of
deferred as having two chains of
callbacks one is used when an
asynchronous operation completes
successfully and the other one and error
occurs before I get into the details of
deferreds
I'd like to go through an example of
converting a piece of synchronous code
into a piece of asynchronous code bird
here's the synchronous code get page
sync
makes a network request for a web page
and blocks until it receives the page or
an error occurs if the pages received
successfully it's passed to the
translate function and the results of
that's passed to the display function if
an error occurs the unavailable function
is called in both cases the cleanup
function runs last in the asynchronous
version
get page async initiates the request for
web page but it doesn't block waiting
for the page for the result to come back
instead it immediately returns with a
deferred which will eventually be fired
when the pages received or the operation
fails this deferred initially has to
empty callback chains and in the code
here we call functions on the deferred
to add callbacks to the chains when this
codes done running control returns to
the reactor and this diagram shows the
callback chains that are set up by the
asynchronous code you can see that the
flow of control is essentially the same
as that of the sync
code on the success case translate
display and clean up are all being
called the difference is that this code
can run independent of when the requests
for the page was made here's a look at
how the reactor interacts with the
application code in the synchronous case
there's only one call into the sink into
the application code after the call to
get page sync the red line shows the
time that the processors blocked before
the page comes back and the translate
display and cleanup functions are run in
the asynchronous case there are two
calls into the application code the
first time get page a sync is called and
the deferred is set up then controller
returns to the reactor the green line
shows the time that the processor that
we're waiting for the page during which
other process other processing can take
place then when the page comes back the
reactor fires the deferred which
transfers control back into the
application code and the translate
display and cleanup functions run now
back to the details of deferreds we can
think of it deferred as having multiple
levels each with a callback and in our
back although either one can be a pass
through the first interfaces for
functions which can be used to construct
the callback chains each of the levels
in this deferred was created by a
different function which is shown on the
right when the asynchronous event
associated with the deferred occurs in
the operation successful the first
function in the callback chain is
invoked and the result with the result
of the operation but if an error occurs
the first function in the urbact chain
is invoked with the error
program flow doesn't necessarily go
straight down the chains when an error
occurs in either a callback or an ER
back the next call is to the ER back at
the next level down similarly if a
callback or inner back function
completes without an error its return
value is passed to the callback at the
next level down this allows an ER back
function to correct an error and allow
normal processing to proceed and it
allows an error in a callback function
to be handled by error processing code
that's all I have to say about deferreds
they're an important part of twisted but
for the code we'll be
twisted uses them under the covers as we
move into the abstractions that twisted
uses for networking let's first take a
look at the networking model used in the
Internet
the Internet Protocol suite consists of
four layers of functionality the two
lowest the link and network layers are
responsible for sending packets across
the network the transport layer is
responsible for transmission of bytes
between two peers TCP is a
connection-oriented transport layer
protocol which provides a reliable
stream of bytes UDP is an unreliable
connectionless transport layer protocol
and SSL or more properly TLS provides an
encrypted byte stream the application
layer provides meaning to the bytes that
are being transmitted over the transport
layer
it's protocols are used to provide user
services over a network in addition to
HTTP FTP and SMTP there's also pop and
IMAP for retrieving mail DNS for address
revolute resolution IRC for chat and a
lot more at the transport and
application layers we can think of there
being a virtual connection between peers
at the transport layer bytes are being
exchanged well if the application layer
higher-level messages are being passed
let's see how the four layer internet
model maps into twisted twisted relies
on the operating system to provide link
and network layer functionality and it
uses a sockets API for some transport
layer functionality but twisted provides
a transport abstraction which hides the
details of sockets the equivalent of the
application layer in twisted is called a
protocol the terminology here can get
confusing so I'll be careful to
distinguish between application layer
protocols and twisted protocols twisted
uses three basic abstractions for all of
its networking entwisted a transport
represents one end of a connection
between two endpoints over which bytes
can be sent and received a twisted
protocol represents one end of an
application layer protocol which
determines the format and the meaning of
bytes that are sent and received over a
transport and a protocol factory is used
to create the appropriate protocol when
a new connection is established it's
needed to remember what type of protocol
should could be
would be created in the time between
when the reactor starts listening for
connection requests or initiates a
connection and when the connections
actually established in twisted a
protocol is always paired with a
transport but because they're distinct
it's very easy to mix and match them
HTTP usually runs over a TCP connection
but with twisted it's very easy to run
it over SSL to provide HTTPS twisting
also provides special transports for
testing which would be difficult to do
over real network connections this
diagram shows the flow of information
between proto the protocol transport
reactor and operating system to send a
message or drop a connection a protocol
calls a method on its transport and a
transport lets it's protocol know when
data has been received or the status of
the connections changed the transport
uses the underlying operating system
sockets API for network communication
and an interact with the reactor which
uses the pole or event notification API
for detecting events with an
understanding of twisted networking
abstractions let's take a look at some
examples which demonstrate the use of
one of twisted slow level api's one of
the most basic programs we can write
with twisted is an echo server it
accepts connections from from clients
and sends back an identical copy of the
data it receives this is the entire
program for an echo server using twisted
it consists of an echo server class
which is a protocol and an echo server
factory which is a protocol factory
before we start running the reactor we
tell it to listen for connection
requests on port 8000 and give it an
echo server factory to use to create an
echo server protocol for each new
connection then we start the reactor and
wait for events when a connection
request is received a new transport is
created and the build protocol method on
the protocol factory for the listening
port is called to create the appropriate
type of protocol in this case an echo
server protocol later on when data is
received by the echo server protocol
it simply writes the data back to its
transport now let's take a look at the
corresponding echo client the patterns
very similar to the echo server it again
consists of a protocol and a protocol
factory this time to start the program
we tell the reactor to connect to a
specific host import give it and give it
a factory which will create an echo
server an echo client protocol when the
connections established and then we kick
off the reactor the difference between
the echo server and the echo client
shows up in the protocol in the server
version we use the default connection
made implement a fault implementation of
connection made which is called right
after protocol is created in the client
version we override this function to
send a message to the server since we're
talking to an echo server we should get
back the same message we sent when we do
data receive will be called and will
print out the receives message and then
tell the transport to drop the
connection notice that through the write
functions on the transport and the data
receive function on the protocol we have
access to the stream of bytes being sent
and received over the transport layer
using this low-level API we could
develop our own twisted protocol which
implements an application layer protocol
of our own design we could also develop
one which implements a standard
application protocol but the really nice
thing is that we don't have to do that
because twisted has already developed a
series of protocols which implements
standard application layer protocols and
it provides high level api's for using
them next we'll take a look at one
standard protocol and the API that
twisted provides to use it
SMTP stands for Simple Mail Transfer
Protocol
it's a connection-oriented text-based
protocol for sending email since it's
text-based we can use telnet to connect
to a mail server send messages and see
the server's response each response from
the server begins with a three-digit
code followed by text in this tell net
session we can see that once we've
connected to the server we receive a 220
response indicating that the servers
ready to start
mail session we send a intentionally
misspelled hello command and the server
replies with a 250 code which means that
everything's okay to start standing an
email we send a mail from command which
includes the address of the email sender
then we send at least one but possibly
multiple receipt to commands which
specify the intended recipients of the
mail then we're ready to send the body
of the message which starts with a data
command the server sends a 354 reply
which means that it's waiting for the
body of the message
finally we send the message itself
followed by a period
at this point we could send another
message by starting over with the mail
from command
or we could terminate the session by
typing quit if we wanted to use twisted
to build an SMTP client to send out a
set of messages we could create a new
twisted protocol probably organize it as
a state machine and it would initially
send out a hello command and then
repeatedly cycle through the mail from
receipt to and data commands to send out
each mail message it would need to parse
each response from the server and handle
error conditions Twista gives us all the
tools to build an SMTP client but the
really great thing about twisted is that
it already includes an SMTP client that
does almost all of that in order to be
general-purpose
information about the messages to be
sent have to be provided to twist its
SMTP client and twisted offers an API
for that purpose for each piece of
information that the SMTP client needs
to send to the server it calls an
internal function to get the information
it repeatedly cycles through the calls
to get mail from get mail to and get
data until get mail from returns none
which means there are no more messages
to send and after each message is sent
the SMTP client calls the sent mail
function to use this API we need to
subclass a SMTP client and override
these functions to provide information
about the messages we want to send let's
use this API to build a client to send a
single message to a mail server will
make our single message sender a
subclass of SMTP client which is
itself a subclass of protocol and will
save the information about our message
as instance variables the underlying
SMTP client takes care of constructing
the SMTP messages and parsing the server
responses when it's time to send each
piece of information about the mail
message the SMTP client gets it by
calling the appropriate API function
which we've provided after cycling
through the three API functions one time
the SMTP client calls get mail from a
second time to see if there's another
message and our get mail function
returns none get mail from function
returns none to say there are no more
messages to send now let's use our
single message client to send a single
message to a mail server to make things
really easy let's create a function
which takes as parameters the address
and port of a mail server the three
pieces of information about a message
and a reactor instance it creates a
single message sender Factory which I
have not shown and initiates a
connection to the server this is the
same pattern that we saw in the echo
client so let's add a bit of code to use
our send message function first we'll
define the body of the message then
we'll call send message and tell it to
connect to the server running on port 80
25 of localhost and give it the sender
and recipient addresses the body of the
message and the reactor since we don't
have a reactor running yet we'll start
one but if we need it to send a message
out as part of a larger event driven
program we could pass in the reactor
that was already running in case you
want to play around with this at home
you should know that the standard port
for SMTP is port 25 but a lot of ISPs
block it to prevent spam so here we're
sending to a server running locally on
port 80 25 a minute we'll see how to
start up this server what we just did
was used twisted SMTP client API to
create a specialized client that sends
one message and we wrote a function to
connect to a server and use that client
to send a message at this point you may
not be surprised that twisted comes with
this functionality included as well
the twisted equivalence of our single
message sender and single message sender
Factory are the SMTP sender and SMTP
sender factory twisted also includes a
version of the send mail function which
can easily be used within larger event
driven programs to shoot off a message
SMTP has been superseded by another
protocol extended SMTP which offers it's
similar but it offers authentication and
other options twisted also provides
esmtp equivalents for all the SMTP
classes on the server-side Twista
provides implementations of SMTP and E
SMTP servers which are configurable in
terms of what addresses they accept mail
for and where they place the mail this
hood also provides full SMTP and E SMTP
server applications which can easily be
run from the command line using the
twisty utility and now we'll circle back
to Twisted batteries included approach
twisted provides an infrastructure for
building applications and twisty is a
cross-platform utility for deploying
them
it handles starting and stopping
applications and supports logging and
immunization as we saw twisted provides
application versions of servers for most
of the protocols it includes here's a
twisty command which will start an SMTP
server which accepts the mail we sent
with our single message client it runs
on port 80 25 and accepts mail for the
user named recipient on the example.com
domain it stores the mail under slash
temp slash example.com so we talked
about her twisted provides building
blocks for creating network applications
and why event driven up the event-driven
approach works well for them then we
talked about the basic abstractions that
twisted uses the reactor and des froze
make it possible for Twisted T to take
an event-driven approach and transport
protocols and protocol factories are the
basis of all of twisted networking
Twista provides low-level api's which
allow access to the stream of bytes over
the transport layer while hiding the
gory details of sockets and other
operating system functions and Twista
provides high-level api's which make it
easy to write
clients and servers for standard
protocols and if that weren't enough
twist it becomes batteries included with
working clients and servers implementing
many of the standard many of the
standard protocols which can be run
right from the command line using the
twisty utility twist it provides a lot
of functionality I've only scratched the
surface but the abstractions that we've
discussed run throughout twisted if
you'd like to learn more I can recommend
some great resources an online tutorial
a book and the Twitter website which
includes examples tutorials and a lot of
documentation now I have a few minutes
for some questions
what am I using twister for I well I
started out just I wrote a BitTorrent
client and initially I wrote the event
loop in straight Python and then I
converted it over to use twisted and I
also wrote an IRC server just as a
project and I use twisted for the for
the basic networking it's it takes care
of a lot of the edge cases and the stuff
where if you were writing it yourself
you'd eventually run into problems and
have to fix them twisted is much more
robust I use a tornado for synchronous
web programming I I don't have any
experience with your tornado sorry but
is is tornado just web server I think so
okay so twisted is a lot more
general-purpose you can use twisted
anywhere from just taking care of the
socket connections and writing your own
protocol for for talking to another
computer to all these other standard
protocols besides web access the other
thing I did in my BitTorrent client was
I made a I also have the same program
running a web server which I used to and
I wrote a very little JavaScript
front-end to control it to tell it when
to start a torrent and giving feedback
on how much had come back and twisted
has a really great piece of it where you
can very easily define your own
protocols and that's what I did and so
just a very little bit of code
translated into a lot of functionality
hi thanks umm I'd be curious to know
what companies use twisted in production
and what are the primary applications I
know that a company called Zula which
just got acquired by Dropbox and I think
Dropbox may also use twisted and I know
that they do their mail stuff with it I
off the top of my head I don't I I don't
know other companies but I do know that
there are twist is used in a lot of
projects
so ideally would this be used primarily
for prototyping because you've mentioned
that it could also perform some of the
native services like FTP so from my
perspective why would I want to redo
something like FTP and twisted when my
OS would perfectly provide FTP services
without it so if I had a custom protocol
I see that this does have a lot of
potential but for a lot of the basic
services why well one reason you might
want to do this is if you want to have
one program with multiple Network things
going on at the same time like in my
example with my BitTorrent client I was
doing the BitTorrent protocol using
twisted and I was also running a web
server with twisted and by doing it with
twisted you can run all these
applications as part of the same program
and share data very very easily so that
might be a reason hi I'm almost alone
among the the major tools for Python
twisting doesn't support Python 3 do you
have any idea what the reason for that
is I mean is there some what what's what
reason do you suppose it is I think you
might know more about this than I do
I'm not sure I think I think there is an
effort underway to convert to Python 3
but it's it's not there yet but but I
think it's in process